twisted heaps of metal slabs of fallen
concrete and workers scrambling to clear
away pieces of several buildings the
destruction caused by missiles thursday
night a reminder that russia is not
finished with keith
my daughter and i wear the kitchen and
there was an explosion at the time i
first saw a flash and then heard the
sound pavlov kozetsky just returned with
his family a few days ago thinking it
was safe his youngest child thought the
thud of the missile striking a building
near his was thunder his older children
understand ukraine has been dragged into
a war
we are very angry our country is under
attack from russia
and i agreed to fight against this
country for sake of my daughters at
least eight buildings in the
chevchchenkivsky district in the capital
sustained damages in the strikes one
woman a journalist verahirich was killed
in her home
russia claims it used five precision
missiles and destroyed a weapons factory
workshop
as the largest land war in europe since
the second world war stretches on and
more lives are lost the level of anger
rises
i will collect molotov cocktails just in
case and we will remove those bandits
from our country and we will remember
everyone
maintaining a fighting spirit is not
easy especially when you've lost your
home
earlier it's so plain it was not scaring
me but now i have a fear anastasia
invited global news into her bombed out
building in european but didn't feel up
to appearing on camera she says she's
salvaging what she can
and feels better
he recently bought this apartment
and we really liked the city the city
became very close to us
european is just outside of kiev in
mid-march people started fleeing because
of shelling but many were killed or
wounded on the roads trying to escape
russian forces
the area was held for a short time as
russia prepared to descend on the
capital
infrastructure in previously occupied
areas is a major problem do you want me
to open this so i can see this was the
bridge if you can call it that that we
used to leave the city
some of the infrastructure was destroyed
by russia other parts were taken out by
ukrainians trying to delay the troops
from getting to keep
roads utilities even water is still in
the process of being restored in many
areas in cities such as european and
bucha city officials are encouraging
businesses to reopen so people can
access supplies to rebuild or at least
patch things up and make them livable
with the renewed attacks here in kiev
the question is is it too soon
chris crystal gomezing in kiev thanks
very much crystal